i just have to ask i mean you were just
at britney's wedding with the biggest
female icons
of all time right now i think it was all
the people that loved her and that was
all that matters
oh goody the murderers are here we were
framing all of you on the podcast still
have that boom mic you bet your ass i do
kid well i don't actually i returned it
in the 30 day window to get my deposit
but i can get it back all right hi guys
congratulations on another season um
thank you at the outset of this
friendship steve and martin you guys
told us that selena taught you all kinds
of new things through your first season
one of them being the definition of [ __ ]
what did we learn in season two from
selena in this ongoing friendship oh god
i don't oh
things that can't be repeated we're
we're teaching her things about how how
romances can so easily go wrong
are you really yeah i think the i think
the rules are more reversed i i so just
enjoy trying to make them laugh but it's
more so the other way around oh yeah
what's something that they've taught you
selena well i think in general i've said
this before but i think in general my
standards for humor and gentlemen and
just
uh professionals um have been you know
the bar's been lifted pretty high
working with these two so it's been
really fun but i'm now a little bit
picky
yeah selena haven't you always though
worked with extreme professionals you
never had like nut cases i've never had
a bad case at all but i will say that
it's it's been very different than my
past experiences
i can see that i can see that so
given what you've just said i mean
oliver and charles meddle in mabel's
relationship a little bit this season
are these guys meddling in your
real-life romantic relationships are
they trying to set you up with anybody
no
no just just me
you guys haven't you guys have don't
have a rolodex of protective they're
we're very protective of her but but you
know most of the people you know are
dead we don't know anyone under 50. so
it's not like uh say i want you to meet
selena if you get out of that walker
maybe you can meet selena maybe your
friends have kids
um i'm fine i don't need i don't need
anyone yeah yeah she's fine yeah
uh celina what was it like for you
shooting with cara this season having
these you know quieter more intimate
moments so much fun i've known her for
so many years it was honestly like
working with a childhood friend i've i
just enjoyed it she's hilarious i think
she did so great this season and adds to
the show completely so
i had a blast and she's a great hang
yeah yeah really fun and and for me
working with marty is like hanging out
with a childhood friend who's still a
child
[Laughter]
this season we have the uh
the podcast groupies the fans are back
in action as sort of this greek chorus
um how much could you guys relate to the
power of fandom and i don't know it's
sometimes not even being able to escape
it they're ever present in your life i
don't have any fans
nobody did
once fandom has really changed from when
i was you know younger it was a very
different thing now fans used to be
someone who hung outside
your gig and asked for an autograph but
now they're contacting you through i
mean the younger stars through
social media and all kinds of other
other ways to
you know either be kind or be aggressive
you know
it's a little trickier now is there any
aspect of you that that wishes that
social media were more
of a of a thing when you were so coming
up
so that you could have that experience
or no you look at that and go like oh
not me at all
no no not not at all i'm not on social
media at all for the for that reason i'm
glad i didn't have it and and you know
for a while i really got invested in
twitter just being funny
uh and then that environment kind of
changed a little bit man no i can
understand that um selena you've spoken
about how
tick-tock is like the kindest of the
platforms
is there any chance of you getting these
guys on tick-tock at all making some
some kind and fun videos
no i think right now we're just excited
to be working together and you know
obviously doing
another season and stuff i think that's
kind of
more
where we live yeah
but you posted some videos about some
tick tock right i posted a few of you
guys yes it was kind of fun
i love that she did it without warning
we just look over and she's videoing
[Laughter]
so celina for you is it like when the
creative inspiration
sparks you've gotta you've gotta make a
quick tick tock or do you plan it out no
not at all i just enjoy it and
have fun that's all that's all i do yeah
now as you said uh cara is a great hang
she's a lot of fun
you guys have got incredible guest stars
i don't want to spoil anything for
anybody but there's phenomenal
performers who show up to hang out with
you guys this season
i would imagine people are just like
lining up to come and do this show right
i don't know i mean we just
we do certainly have great guest stars i
would like to think people are lining up
we can we can talk about shirley
maclaine mm-hmm i know dicaprio wanted
to do it but i didn't i felt there was a
conflict with my character
and um meryl you know
she said they're begging we'll see
my phone i'm sorry meryl sorry no no
maybe
sorry maybe next season yeah selena
maywell this season is an icon she's
certainly looking out for other women
this season um i just have to ask i mean
you were just at britney's wedding with
the biggest female icons of all time
right now what was it like to be there
with donatella madonna drew barrymore
and be there to support brittany
um i think it was a day for love and i
want nothing more than happiness and
burn so it was
i don't know i think it was all the
people that loved her and that was all
that matters steve martin were you guys
jealous that you didn't get invites to
this a plus one and a plus two
well you know they kept it they kept it
from me
so i didn't even hear about the wedding
till way later so i didn't even and by
that time it was so much in the past i
didn't even have a memory of reading the
headline yeah i mean i sent brittany a
letter the next day saying uh what was
that about
yeah all right to be excluded hurt
you